[Music]
muscles some are big some are small
and some are fake including both
skeletal and smooth muscle they make up
about
82 percent of your body weight skeletal
muscle the muscle that you actually see
on the human body
allows us to move by exacting forces on
our bones
smooth muscle the ones you don't see act
as pumps and tubing within our body
the human body has over 800 different
muscles and i'm willing to bet you can
only name about
five or six let me guess biceps pecs
traps abs quads and maybe calves
congratulations you know nothing about
the human muscular system
but you're not alone most people don't
know much about their own muscles
except that they can make them swole
for example most people think that this
is a tendon
and some may even think it's a bone it's
neither it's a muscle called the
sternocleidomastoid
it's attached at the sternum the
clavicle and the mastoid process
hence the name sternocleidomastoid
the sternocleidomastoid allows you to
rotate your head and flex your neck
otherwise your roughly 10 pound head
would not stay up straight at all
what about this muscle on your forearm
this is the extensor digitorum
communists
its function is to extend your fingers
case in point
but in case you notice the muscle is way
over here
and the fingers are extending over here
there is muscle in the forearm for sure
but the wrists and palm are pretty flat
and
have nowhere near as much muscle that's
because right here in the back of your
hand
are long stringy tendons called the
extensor digitorum tendons
when the extender digitorum communist
muscle contracts
it pulls the tendons back and extends
the fingers if you ever got into an
accident where the tendons in the back
of your hand are damaged or even severed
your fingers will not be able to move at
all
how about your lungs nearly everyone
assumes that when you breathe
it's because your lungs are sucking in
air your lungs are not a muscle
they do nothing they're just elastic
sacs that inflate when air fills them
the way you breathe is not through your
lungs but rather your diaphragm
the diaphragm is a muscle that sits at
the bottom of your chest cavity
and allows you to breathe by changing
the pressure inside your lungs
when you exhale the diaphragm moves
upward putting pressure on your
lungs and forcing air out similar to
squeezing a balloon
air cannot go into the balloon because
air is being forced out
in contrast when you breathe in your
diaphragm moves downward
allowing the lungs to expand thereby
reducing pressure
now the air pressure is higher outside
your body and air can flow into your
lungs where the pressure is now
lower that sensation you think you feel
of inhaling air
is not real you think it's real but it's
just a pressure differential acting on
your body
okay here's an easy one what's the
longest muscle in the body
hint it's below the waist
and i just walked into that one but it's
not that muscle
okay guys the longest muscle in the body
is the sartorius muscle
a relatively obscure muscle it measures
nearly 20 inches in length
almost 2 feet long or 3 and 1 3 hot dogs
it connects at the interior iliac spine
wraps around your quads and ends at the
upper tibia below your knee
oh but what does it do just flexes your
hips and knees that's
pretty much it but it is the longest
muscle in the body finally
do you know how urination works well i
hate to tell you but the bladder is not
a muscle
it's just an elastic reservoir that
holds liquid waste
instead urine is expelled by way of the
detrusor muscle
a smooth muscle that surrounds a bladder
upon activation of the pelvic nerve the
detrusor muscle contracts around the
bladder
pushing urine into the urethra and out
the body
while we're on the subject of anatomy
did you know that there's a bone
literally floating in your throat yeah
it's called the hyoid bone
and there's no other bone connected to
it it's just sitting there
form your fingers like you're holding a
small matchbox and place them where your
jaw meets your throat
right above your trachea once you find
it you can actually wiggle it back and
forth
yeah it's pretty gross sorry if i ruined
your day but uh hey
thanks for watching